فجرت قوه الاحتلال المنزله عائله الشهيد
محمد الجعبري المتهمي بقتل مستوطن واصابه
اخر في اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي في
منطقه قرب قرب مستوطنه كريات اربع شرقيه
مدينه الخليل وكانت وحده هندسيه عسكريه
خاصه بحمايه الاحتلال قد اقتحمت المنزل
ليله امس ووضعت فيه مواد متفجره بعد ان
هدمت الجدران الخارجيه للمنزل
من رام الله مراسله الجزيره جيفارا المدير
تنضم الينا جيفارا تصعيد على مستوى او عده
مستويات في ممارسات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ولكن من ابرز عناوينه هو هذا العقاب
الجماعي ضعينا في تفاصيل هذا المشهد وهذا
التصعيد في الممارسات
نبدا من الخليل من منطقه تسمى بقوزين هي
قريبه من مستوطنه اربع قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت هذه المنطقه ليله امس اجبرت سكان
البنايه السكنيه التي تقتلها عائله
الشهيده محمد الجعبري هو في الطابق الاخير
هذا المنزل ولكنها اجبرت كل سكان البنايه
والبنايات المجاوره على المغادره والبقاء
في العراء في ساعات البرد القارس قامت
وحده هندسيه خاصه
بتدمير الجدران بدايه ومع ساعات الفجر
قامت بعد تجهيز متفجرات بتفجير المنزل
بالكامل وليس لمره واحده بل على مرتين
والركام وكانه زلزال في منطقه صغيره في
ذات السياق قام مستوطنون
بالغناء بالقاء الالعاب النا ابتهاجا
بعمليه التفجير لمنزل الشهيد محمد الجعبري
الذي كان قد استشهد في اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي بعد قيامه بزعم قوات الاحتلال بقتل
مستوطن واصابه اخر قربه مستوطنه كريات
اربع وهي القريبه من منزل عائلته بالطبع
في المنزل كان يسكن الزوجه والاطفال ولكن
وفق ايضا هذا العقاب الجماعي وهدم المنازل
لا يخلو الامر ايضا عن الحديث عن القدس
وفق مؤسسات مقدسيه حقوقيه فان مسلخ هدم
المنازل هكذا بدا يوصف هذا المشهد نتحدث
وفق هذه المؤسسات عن اكثر من 9800 منزل
ومنشاه مهدده بالهدم وتسلمه اختارات الهدم
بحجه البناء بدون ترخيص ولكن بالطبع الشغل
لكل الفلسطينيين الان هو ما يحدث في داخل
سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الهجمه على
الاسرى البدء بخطوات ستنتهي في الاول من
رمضان بالاضراب الذي يصفه الاسرى بانه
اضراب الحريه او الاستشهاد اخر ما وصلنا
من داخل السجون الاسرائيليه في ظل التعتيم
الكامل على الاسرى هو تحديدا في سجني
جلبوع ونفحه تقليل كميات المياه ان يصل
الامر الى السماح لكل اسير بالاستحمام فقط
لمده دقيقه واحده بنصف كميه المياه نكهيكه
عن كل ما
يصفهيه لاسرى قدوا سنوات شبابهم في داخل
سجون الاحتلال الاخطر بالطبع الان كما
ذكرتيه هو موضوع سحب الاقامه او الجنسيه
من الاسرى سواء الذين تحرروا او الذين لا
زالوا في سجون الاحتلال ان سحبت هذه
الجنسيه الاسرائيليه من اسرى الداخل هم لا
يملكون اي وث او جنسيه اخرى ينتقلون فيها
حتى الى اي مكان في العالم او حتى البقاء
في الضفه الغربيه او غزه بينما اسرى القدس
الوضع اصعب ايضا لانهم لا يملكون سوى هويه
اقامه مؤقته كمواطنه لا حتى مستوى جواز
سفر ايضا انسحبت فمعنى ذلك ان الاسير
عندما يتحرر لن يجد اي مكان يذهب اليه
يصبح وكانه مجرد انسان باسم ولكن بلا رقم
بلا وجود على الارض اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
رام الله مراسله الجزيره جيفا